Warren thanks for
this is the RIT M spring lecture series
and were really really thrilled to
welcome professor Christina Heatherton
an assistant professor of American
Studies at Barnard College we just
wanted to say a couple of things kind of
collectively about professor Heatherton
x' work some of which you can see up
here and three things that I think I've
really taken and learned from as I've
engaged her work across a number of
years the first is it's very difficult
to inhabit or we fate will often face a
contradiction and habita an academy that
constantly rewards individuated work and
asks you to imagine collaboration is
sometimes something you do kind of
outside of work but professor Heatherton
really since her time in her PhD program
has developed a practice of
demonstrating that the very best
scholarly work we do is also the work
that has to be most the most robust
foundation for collaboration so you can
see this book the image in the middle
freedom now struggles for the human
right to housing in LA and beyond which
is a volume she co-edited with
organizers who are organizing our issues
of housing and homelessness in LA and
Skid Row artists scholars and others
actually showing why scholarship is at
its best if it's in those kinds of
relationships the same is true for
another co-edited edited project she did
downtown blue is a Skid Row reader and
policing the planet which came out a
couple of years ago with her co-editor
Jordan camp really contains this
remarkable series of essays from a range
of disciplines some by activists and by
scholars it's has all these really rich
interviews where she's actually for
grounding for us the role that kind of
dialogue and exchange can play in
analysis and advancing ideas so I just
want to say these are often projects
that scholars wait for it some like
milestone after all these other
individual forms of like security have
been confirmed
to pursue and professor Heatherton has
modeled how that can be done and it can
be done absolutely kind of aligned with
one scholarly attention the second is
across a number of these and these are
the rising tide of color and feminist
rethink that neoliberal state are edited
volumes that she's contributed essays
toward she has a forthcoming book called
the color line in the class struggle the
Mexican Revolution internationalism and
the American Century from UC press is a
very careful attention to these very
particular sites of material effects and
structural forms of domination broken
windows policing the effects of
unemployment and crisis in the 1930s
always wedded to the types of
relationships and resistance that those
structures produce so you never finish
complete her work feeling like processes
of domination are complete they're
beyond contestation nor do you get the
sense that she's offering us some gloss
on an idealized social movement that
could come she's always showing us the
way in those concrete relations of
domination new possibilities are
emerging and she's giving us a different
way actually to understand what's
happening at these sites and the final
thing I'll say and I think we'll really
see today is that it's often difficult
to think about aesthetics cultural
formation and cultural production has
actually tied to those material
structures either we hide them off and
try to understand them just in the
registers of representation or we think
that they're actually mere kind of like
expressions of the real stuff happening
in the material and Heatherton is one of
the few scholars that actually shows us
that those sites of cultural formation
artistic development and connections are
material sites and they should be read
with seriousness because they have deep
deep consequences so I'm really really
thrilled to welcome her I want to thank
the Yale Center for the Study of race
indigeneity and transnational migration
for sponsoring the series which includes
having guest scholars come to a graduate
seminar I'm teaching on relational
intersectional formations of race please
join me in welcoming professor Kristina
Heatherton
[Applause]
okay good evening everybody need a
little bit more than that good evening
evening so first of all I just have to
thank Dan for that very generous
introduction I'm taking it trying to
take deep breaths and not blush so hard
so just give me a second this I I want
to thank Dan and Steve pity for this
very generous invitation to speak before
all of you tonight for Nicole Edwards
for coordinating this visit it's such an
honor to present at the Center for the
Study of race indigeneity and
transnational migration and I want to
start off just by saying on behalf of
all junior scholars and American and
ethnic studies across the country I want
to thank the faculty and students here
for their consistent courage and
advocacy you know in our work we often
draw on the intellectuals that Cedric
Robinson called renegades and it's
really inspiring to see scholars live up
to that reputation in their research and
in their solidarity so thank you all
tonight I'm going to be talking about
well let me tell you what I'm going to
be talking about from PowerPoint there
we go tonight I will be talking about
Elizabeth Catlett and I'm gonna be
discussing the connections between her
politics radical pedagogy and as Dan
said her cultural work someone recently
asked about the relevance of discussing
cultural work as work right now and I
think this is the right question to be
asking from the new parlance of the gig
economy to the expectations that artists
and writers be compensated for their
work by exposure rather than by wages I
think there's a really pernicious new
logic that tries incessantly to devalue
us and convince us that our work is not
work so you know as a striking students
throughout the UC system are right now
compelling us to understand work as work
it should be understood protected and
compensated as such they're showing us
that the recognition the recognition of
our labor is a struggle for our humanity
and for our dignity so I speak with you
tonight in solidarity with them
so let's get started well how many of
you have heard of those with Catlett
before okay great
I recently spoke to a room and I asked
that question the entire room raised her
hand
so all right so you may know Elizabeth
Catlett as the Dean of black women
artists even if you don't realize that
you know her in art historian Melanie
Hertzog's words she was quote one of the
most important American artists of the
past century and I intend to agree with
that statement internationally acclaimed
for her graphic prints and signature
sculptures
she created a body of work charged with
rage Beauty life and struggle walking
into homes of older activists you're
likely to encounter her work there and
if you read the memoirs children of
these radicals often describe growing up
and running their fingers along the soft
contours of her sculptures and comfort
and amazement in these ways Elizabeth
Catholic work provides the ambient
texture too radical history in the
United States many of you are probably
familiar with her widely reproduced
sharecropper lithograph or her Black
Power era prints okay I just want to
make sure everything's working her work
celebrates black women motherhood
collectivity while also really
dramatically representing state
repression and works like some of the
ones I'll show you here like Target
which is at the end which was a tribute
to Fred Hampton and Mark Clark - Bart
Black Panthers who were murdered by the
Chicago Police Department or in other
images such as the torture of mothers
which was made after the 1964 police
beating of children and Harlem she calls
attention to racist police violence and
I want to be clear that her work was
consciously and consistently made and
dialogue with political struggle both
nationally and internationally in
defense in Central America say it says
no which she incorporated elements of
another image called Chile - she
condemns the 1973 us back coup and Chile
in Chile
she features a Seoul
you're blinding a protester a poignant
image that resonates with Chilean
protests against neoliberalism and
similar military tactics going on right
now so I don't know how many of you seen
protesters cover their eye in protest
the hands in the image honor Victor Jara
beloved singer and guitar player whose
fingers were brutally broken before he
was executed before a horrified Stadium
of people but the hands here are joyous
and they clinched as fists together
I think Catlett's images evoke pain fear
joy and resilience I have given the
world my song she says in another to
consider Elizabeth Cavett then is to
behold a beloved artist whose work seems
to be everywhere but whose story is
hiding in plain sight Catlett is mostly
mentioned in relation to her one-time
husband Charles White another artists of
great prominence who I won't be talking
about too much today but if you have
questions about Charles white I'll happy
happily answer Katla's name is peppered
through histories of the black left in
the 30s and 40s if she is referenced on
her own it's mostly as a friend or
fellow traveler of other self-declared
radicals biographies and scholarly texts
often downplay or minimize Catlett's
politics and this is of course in no
small part due to an image that Catholic
cultivated herself within a Cold War
context one that her biography her
biographers conceivably respected since
the viability of her professional career
was perceived to be contingent on this
perceived distance we can understand
that Catlett was careful in public
performance to keep her political cards
close especially if we considered our
league Darlene Clarke Hines concept of
dissemble and the appearance of openness
with shields which shields black women
particularly in public life from
scrutiny as Mary Helen Washington
describes this biographical performance
was sometimes necessary for the survival
of black artists who were organizing on
the Left in the Cold War namely
Elizabeth Catlett by the time Catlett
had her first solo show at the Studio
Museum in Harlem in 1971 she had been
effectively shut out of the US market
for dead
Cades for most of her life she lived and
worked in Mexico a place that Simone
Brown reminds us is also home to the
oldest FBI field office in the world
Catlett had long been on the FBI's
watchlist after marrying her husband
Francisco Mota and becoming a Mexican
citizen she was repeatedly denied a visa
to come to the United States this meant
of course that she couldn't come to
conferences or gallery shows she
couldn't come and speak in front of a
student said Yael even when her mother
was dying she was refused entry into the
country to see her by the time
organizers campaign to get her back into
the country she had suffered setbacks to
her career into our livelihood so we can
perhaps sympathize with some of her
reticence to be totally open about her
politics but it might now be time to
think knew about Elizabeth Catlin who
was this person that the FBI watched so
closely why did she incur this level of
surveillance
why was she deemed an enemy of the state
and what motivated her very political
artwork in the words of Catlett's
longtime friend dr. Gwendolyn midlow
Hall it's time to tell the truth about
this exceptional artist teacher and
organizer at the height of the Red Scare
Catlett was classed an undesirable alien
by the State Department and held in a
Mexican jail for several days she
renounced her US citizenship two years
later under the Immigration and
Nationality Act the US government could
refuse entry to any person perceived to
be a communist and this as her 1964 FBI
file demonstrates is what she was
suspected of being while few sustain
studies have been written about her
politics we can ascertain her political
history in other ways
her name surfaces in the biographies of
radicals who sought refuge in Mexico in
the post-war era when Marvin X teacher
of Huey Newton and co-founder of the
black arts theater was escaping
persecution from California Governor
Ronald Reagan he found shelter with
Catlett in Mexico at that time should be
seeing something else let's see
now that's what happens when you add an
FBI slide to your powerpoints so I'll
keep reading but thanks so at the time
Catlett was actually in the middle of
doing this print on the Black Panthers
when this person was very close to the
Panthers came to Mexico to seek shelter
okay go ahead where was I and this is
what she said to marvin x quote mexico
has always given refuge to
revolutionaries from around the world so
when I interviewed Elizabeth Catlett I
had the enormous privilege to interview
her in Cuernavaca in 2011 she and her
son recounted these wonderful stories of
other radicals who had passed through
their house people like Harry Haywood
who caused this is an adorable story he
caused a blackout in a small Mexican in
because he thought the light was too dim
he had brought his own light and he
screwed it in because he had brought all
these books he wanted to read and in
doing so the whole place blacked out
adorable as Diana and halts gathering of
fugitives and Rebecca Schreiber's
excellent cold war exhales in Mexico
detail Khalid assisted many many people
who are fleeing to Mexico including
those who were escaping car theism and
the blacklist Spanish refugees who were
fleeing Franco's fascism and black
radicals who were fleeing u.s. state
repression among others as she noted in
a 1975 interview with Raquel teabowl
quote the revolutionary atmosphere in
which I developed in Mexico was
determinant in my development and
projection so today's book comes from
today's book almost today's presentation
comes from a book I am writing the title
slightly changed it's now called making
internationalism the color line the
class struggle and the Mexican
Revolution and the and at some point I'm
going to show you a great image of the
cover but right now you'll just have to
imagine it the book follows the
internationalization of US capital in
the early 20th century and it traces the
concurrent history of radicals who saw
it clarity on the specific intersection
of the color line and the class struggle
it explores how artists writers writers
and revolutionaries other
revolutionaries developed an emergent
form of anti-racist internationalism it
observed how they theorize dramatized
and challenged the racist and gendered
social relations under capitalism and
concurrent and consequently how they
develop new articulations of struggle it
argues that their international visions
provided a revolutionary alternative to
the politics promoted by u.s.
imperialism and following their lead if
foregrounds the influence of the Mexican
Revolution the first major social
revolution of the 20th century so the
book is organized around what I call
convergent spaces these are socio
spatial sites where multiple radical
traditions are compressed together in
struggle and in space so today with how
to make address I'll be looking at some
of the many converging spaces that were
critical to Catlett's formation for the
first 30 or so years of her life
I'll briefly and I wish we had more time
but only briefly discuss Chicago
Southside Community Arts Center
I'll speak at length about her time at
the George Washington Carver School in
Harlem and finally I'll talk about the
Toyota graphic a popular or the tgp an
internationalist art collective in
Mexico City recovering the life of
Elizabeth Catlett through these
converging spaces helps us understand
not only an overlooked biography but I
think a submerged theory of
internationalism that is critical for
our present moment in her art work and
in her teaching and in her thinking
Catlett placed black working-class women
particularly domestic women sorry
particularly black domestic workers at
the heart of the global anti imperialist
class struggle so by situating Catlett
within the radical millou's that
produced her and that she in turn helped
to produce I argue that we can more
fully comprehend the radical anti-racist
feminist internationalist politics of
her work and in doing so we follow
Tiffany Ruby Patterson Myers injunction
to quote bring the gendered in-class
contours of internationalism out of the
shadows so where shall we begin
okay there are what you saw enough
pictures right no problem no problem
we'll make it work so I might have to
show you a lot of images with my hands
so there's a lot of places that we could
start to talk about Elizabeth Catlett we
could begin in Catlett's young life
coming of age in Jim Crow DC as Paula
Austin describes as a student in Dunn at
Dunbar High School in the early 1930s
she was protesting she was arrested for
protesting lynching in front of the
Supreme Court with a noose around her
neck in Catlett's words quote I was
radical since I was young we could begin
a few years later while she was a
disillusion undergraduate at Howard
University there she befriended a young
communist named Pauline Meyers who was a
boarder renting a room in her mother's
home Myers was a firebrand speaker at
anti-war anti-fascist demonstrations
she taught Catlett about Marxism and
anti-colonialism things Catlett said in
a 1983 oral history that she quote never
learned in school Myers also brought
friends to the house including a number
of African socialists one of whom would
kneel at Catlett's grandmother's feet
and say I'm sitting at your feet
grandmother tell me about slavery and
this by the way is how Catlett learned
about her own family's history of
slavery through these conversations so
through these experience Catlett
understood for education very broadly
encompassing radical theory her family's
own history and the world at war around
her we might also start in Durham North
Carolina where Catlett got her first
teaching job and learned pedagogy and
protests at the same time here during
the Depression she was horrified to see
working-class black students especially
girls being cheated out of their
education mostly trained to make socks
for a nearby Factory she helped organize
a campaign to address pay discrepancies
between black and white teachers but in
doing so she also learned the dynamics
of what she called black monopoly
capitalism while she was attuned to anti
black racism she came to understand the
vicious class structure within Durham's
black community she saw how local black
capitalists and bankers utilized bribes
withheld loans and deployed gendered
to discipline the local population into
acquiescing to the reigning order I
learned a lot in Durham she said Catlett
escaped to study art at the University
of Iowa why because there was no
out-of-state tuition I relate she began
working with Grant Wood painter of the
iconic American Gothic here I wish I had
a slide but American Gothic you know the
father and the daughter with the
pitchfork you can all see it in your
mind's eye right so this is who she
worked with at the University of Iowa
Wood was of course famous for depicting
the rural Iowa landscapes that he knew
best he encouraged Catlett to depict
what she knew best so she began painting
and later sculpting black working-class
women particularly black domestic
workers in uniform and black mothers
this was perhaps a tribute to her own
mother who had taken on many jobs
including as a seamstress a truant
officer and later a domestic worker to
provide for Catlett her siblings and her
grandmother and it was also possibly in
recognition of the local black women in
Iowa among whom Catlett lived and
socialized Catlett won an illustrious
prize for her thesis sculpture mother
and child when she graduated in 1939
Catlett became one of the first people
ever to earn an MFA in Fine Arts and the
first black woman at the University of
Iowa to do so we could also discuss you
see these are all hypotheticals we could
but we're not really giving you a taste
we could discuss Catlett's time at
Prairie View College near Houston Texas
there she first encountered in the
particular racism of that place in their
Catlett first encountered buildings with
three separate entrances main doors for
white people side doors marked colored
and other side doors marked Mexican she
and her friends were stopped they were
chased by speeding cars and they were
threatened by local racist Texas
segregation for Catlett was a revelation
that's her word and each of these
experienced Catlett came to develop a
sense that teaching meant making
political decisions about the world one
lived in and the world one chose or
chose not to reproduce as an art
professor at Dillard College a
historically black college in New
Orleans Catlett developed a reputation
a local Hellraiser that's actually what
she was known as she lived at four to
six dolphine Street in the French
Quarter among very poor white families
black and white sex workers and a
staggering white countess who she said
looked like something out of this
streetcar named desire only her new
colleague st. Clair Drake would visit
her and Drake came by after several
black Dillard students were arrested
falsely accused of removing the signs
that demarcated the segregated sections
on the local bus I want to be clear that
such signs were routinely removed by
local people in New Orleans including
Catlett herself who is finally
remembered in a lot of memoirs of people
who knew her at the time she was finally
remembered for always tearing them down
sometimes she'd just rip them down throw
them in front of the bus driver and say
you do your own dirty work
so kalloch contacted raymond Tillman who
is part of a Marxist group she was in at
the time Tillman local n-double-a-cp
secretary and also head of the transport
Union agreed to represent the students
the case was quietly resolved since the
chair of Dillard's Board of Directors it
appeared was also the chief stockholder
of the bus company in 1941 Catlett
famously desegregated the local Delgado
Art Museum by having a bus drive a
hundred and sixty black students from
Dillard to the museum's front door to
see a Picasso exhibit by the way the
only other time this has happened we're
like the technology blew up was the
first time I was ever evaluated as a
professor so it was I'm like I might
just be cursed but I appreciate you all
being with me I'm gonna have you imagine
another picture in just a second so get
your brains ready okay so Calvin
desegregated this local art museum and
the way it was saturated the or the
museum itself wasn't formally segregated
but it was housed in the middle of this
park which was so Catlett understanding
that she had all these black students at
Dillard who were studying art but had
never been in an art museum said this
she got a bus to take all 160 students
to the front door of the museum and they
all went in to see this Picasso exhibit
some of her students that day including
sumela Lewis who
you know later became her friend and
biographer they credited this moment to
the the first day of their journey to
becoming artists not too long ago I
talked to another new in New Orleans
artist named Willie birch who grew up in
the city and he described how this act
reverberating for students in New
Orleans for generations
so students stayed at the delgado for
hours amazed to see the art and studying
in particular Picasso's Guernica which
was hanging there at the time so this is
the mural I want you all to try to
imagine how many of you can call up the
image of Guernica and your heads some of
you okay well you we might just have to
do that because I want to stop here with
Guernica just to emphasize that
Catlett's political development was
forged within the struggle against
racism and fascism a struggle that was
being keenly fought out through art and
visual representation Guernica depicted
the fascist fire bombing of a Basque
town a three-hour ordeal where Nazi and
Spanish fascist planes rained down tons
of incendiary bombs this brazen act of
civilians slaughter through new war
technologies was a prelude to the
systematized mass murder that was to
come when the London Times reported on
this attack William LAN described the
air raid using a phrase that would come
to dominate the lexicon of 21st century
war 21st century war he called it
weapons of mass destruction a replica of
Guernica still hangs in the chamber of
the UN Security Council in 2003 when
Colin Powell presented the authorization
for the war on terror falsely arguing
that Iraq had weapons of mass
destruction the Guernica replica was
covered with the blue tarp this move a
UN spokesman said was meant to quote
avert a diplomatic incident Catlett once
described Guernica in a scathing
response to a scholar who called
revolutionary art a meaningless
description in the Mexican paper el Dia
Catlett wrote quote who would dare scorn
the genius of Picasso moved to shout his
anger
in humanity in the mural of Guernica
this tendency is evidence of the
intentions to neutralize and control the
power of art to deny art one of its most
sacred functions and artists one of
their greatest responsibilities to hold
up the mirror of truth and to reveal to
the eyes of humanity the repulsive
presence of the exploitation of man by
man that's the cover in the early 1940s
the struggle against racism and fascism
particularly by the black left was led
by women as Catlett would learn when she
moved to Chicago Margaret Goss burrows
director of the Southside community art
center of the SS CAC brought Catlett
into the fold
so while Catlett had advanced training
in art the SS CAC offered her something
new here politics and culture converged
with rigor joy and intention here she
entered a world that would profoundly
shape her consciousness about arts
relationship to radical internationalist
politics like the Harlem Renaissance
Chicago artists intellectuals and
organizers from part of a vibrant
intellectual and political culture as
authors like Bryan Dolan or bill Mullins
Stacey Morgan and Miriam Kaba have all
described during the so-called Chicago
Renaissance figures like dancer now I
know whatever I say you're gonna be
distracted by this okay but okay well
you would you mind advancing like
probably 20 slides okay all right human
PowerPoint well so let's just do this
really quickly so how to make addresses
the sixth chapter of this book called
making internationalism so you can see
every chapter in the book is about the
making of something you can just advance
we're gonna have to go through probably
like 20 go ahead go ahead
it's the next one so this is Catlett you
know this is an image she did while she
was at Howard this is actually a picture
of her grandmother from the Tulane
archives you can go to the next one
there's a picture of Khaleda she
graduated from the University of Iowa
this is self portrait
would you guys all had this one nailed
right okay very good you can go to the
next one we'll talk about this one in a
second so I won't describe it too much
here I just want to point out one thing
I have special reservations this picture
of a woman on a segregated bus is often
mistakenly you know believed to be Rosa
Parks this is 1946 I want you to think
throughout this whole presentation about
how ahead of her time Elizabeth cally
woods you can go to the next one
Guernica a really low resolution image
from the internet but hopefully it
stirred your imagination of what this
was you can go to the next one all right
so I think we're about where we need to
be this is Margaret Goss Burroughs who I
was just describing so you know
Burroughs along with other figures like
dancer Kathleen Dunham poet Gwendolyn
Brooks photographer Gordon Parks
scholars like Horace Caden and
organizers like Harry Haywood all
flourished many were able to cultivate
their talents independently or through
the alliance of Labor and civil rights
organizations known as the National
Negro Congress as well as through
communist party affiliated John Reid
clubs black artists and the scene
connected local struggles against racism
and poverty to the global fight against
colonialism imperialism and fascism
particularly the Spanish Civil War after
returning from Spain Heywood helped to
organize one of the largest anti-fascist
Peace mobilizations 20,000 marchers
strong and through these relationships
particularly in participants in
Chicago's cultural scene connected local
struggles to a global context developing
support for the global fight against
fascism and in support of the Mexican
Nicaraguan and Haitian people's fights
against US imperialism you can go to the
next one so there's a longer story to
tell about the formation of the South
Side community art center these are some
really glorious pictures from the
Library of Congress a lot of them by
Jack Delano Pablos dad used to work with
it so this place was truly a community
effort funded through extravagant balls
and fundraisers there's a beautiful
story about one of the fundraisers that
I don't have time to tell
in one of them over 20,000 dollars in
donations was collected from a
cross-section of the Southside you can
go to the next one so it's teachers it's
artists gamblers sex workers as well as
white town gallery owners with free art
classes exhibition spaces as well as
artists a place for artists to develop
their own work the center was tremendous
for the community at the opening artists
David Ross said here was our chance to
stop shining shoes all week and painting
on Sunday
this gives us means of learning as well
as a means of earning our living as
artists Catlett's time here was
formative so you can go to the next one
okay so those were all false starts
those are all places we could have
started but here's actually where I
actually want to begin if you can
believe it actually if you can go back
to the one before oh no no no no no I
okay that's fine that's fine that's fine
so I want to set the scene and I was
gonna play you a piece of music here's a
real quiz for you Yale students alright
how many of you can hear in your head
Shostakovich is seventh symphony you
sing it no okay all right so I don't
have the rights to it they said because
this was being filmed I can't play it
for you I'm also not going to hum it it
is a symphony but you can look it up so
I want you to imagine that we're
listening to this very dramatic very
evocative symphony okay and and it's
gonna set the scene Catlett describes it
this way about 350 oaths were squeezed
into a small room sweating on a hot June
night with the windows closed and the
shades drawn and this was because it was
World War 2 there were blackouts in New
York City it was very uncomfortable and
we were listening to Shostakovich his
seventh symphony very dramatic okay
Dmitri Shostakovich is Symphony titled
Leningrad was written during the
devastating Nazi siege of his hometown
in 1941 the symphony had been smuggled
out of Russia by a u.s. agent on micro
in 1942 it was then flown to Tehran
driven through the Middle East and into
Cairo flown to Brazil and then to DC
where the agent almost forgot it on a
lunch tray but recovered it just before
the waiter threw it into the trash drama
after the music was transcribed and
performed by musicians in New York it
was broadcast across the country
offering people in the United States an
intimate vision of the brutal Nazi
assault in that siege over a million
people were cut off from food heat or
contact with the outside world many of
the musicians who had originally
performed it in Russia regularly fainted
from hunger and some of them even died
during rehearsal the symphony was said
to be so powerful they went that when it
was broadcast over loudspeakers in
Leningrad even Nazi soldiers took heart
years later when Nazi remarked on the
quote slow but powerful effect the
symphony had he said we began to see
that there was something stronger than
starvation fear and death the will to
stay human
according to MT Anderson the song marked
a decisive turn in the siege and in the
war and its power was not lost on us
audiences so this is what Catlett and
others had packed into a room in Harlem
to listen to on a hot June night as
Catlett recalled quote a professor from
Juilliard music school had come to play
his record for our students who are
mostly Harlem's people janitors day
workers laundresses cooks elevator
operators and so on the poor black
people who served others in the middle
of the 80-minute symphony the professor
stopped the record said Catlett when the
first movement ended the professor
explained that since the second movement
was very long we could all take a break
and refresh ourselves with some cold
hummus with cold hunch and our students
politely refused they said no the break
can wait we want to hear it all together
how ignorant me I had thought they
weren't interested in classical music
unquote so I bring this up because
Catlett tells this anecdote in many many
interviews to illustrate what she
described in 1996 as her new awareness
of a Cuomo of a quote tremendous hunger
for culture
the students hunger she said in a 2002
New York Times interview made me realize
that artists should create art for
everyone not just an elite the students
she encountered in Harlem were the quote
domestic workers people that worked in
the dress trades people that served
other people their interest and their
desire to learn about literature and art
and economics and history and so forth
was great that is the big experience in
my life
she told this to her she James in 1994
the main method of denial she explained
in 1999 was then and continues to be the
fostering of an elitist culture which
further widens class distinctions
unquote her experiences in Harlem she
said in 1998 made her realize that I had
to work for people
up until then I guess I didn't have any
artist philosophy about what I was doing
and why so I want to turn now to think
about her time teaching in Harlem at the
George Washington Carver School where
she had these revelations and I think
you can go to the next one so when we
think about popular education we often
think about the advances made by people
like Paulo Freire a but with pedagogy of
the oppressed or perhaps the freedom
schools created during the civil rights
movement in the 1960s but as historians
like Marvin gentlemen and Education
scholar Jennison Hunt have argued these
common narratives of popular education
obscure the foundational work done from
the 1920s onward between 1923 and 1957
possibly the largest system of adult
education in America according to
Gettleman was the network of adult
schools organized by labor unions and
the Communist Party these were quote the
functional equivalent of a university
for the working class who could both
learn a vocation and also two and also
enter the quote world of ideas even if
they were kept out of formal elite
institutions of higher education in the
cultural front Michael Dennin quotes a
Croatian immigrant named Stefan JA Roche
whose name I'm probably mangling so
apologies if anybody knows a
pronunciation better so Jaros just as he
described himself was foreign born and
poorly educated like many of the
students who passed through these
schools says JA Roche quote the radical
movement was our teacher it
was a great step to be drawn together in
a group to talk and listen to be induced
to read and study where else could we
get that opportunity during World War
two this network of schools vastly
expanded in the Popular Front area which
emphasized national unity against
fascism schools drew on national
patriotic culture Boston School was
called the Samuel Adams school Chicago's
was named after Abraham Lincoln and
Philadelphia's for Tom Paine in New York
as Denis Lin has recently described the
main school was the Thomas Jefferson
School or the Jeff School and you're
looking at a broadside from it which was
located at 575 six new in the Jeff
school's first publication it used
pretty unapologetic language to describe
its classes and forums
terming them quote mass weapons as sharp
and decisive as bullets in the struggle
against fascism okay so in 1944 no and
you can say in 1944 Catlett joined the
staff of the George Washington Carver
school which was also known as a
people's Institute at 57 West 125th
Street in Harlem between 7th and 8th
Avenue so if other schools were named
after so-called American heroes Harlem's
was named after George Washington Carver
a black agronomist and botanist who made
extraordinary advances in soil
cultivation after reconstruction while
his name is often associated I think
insultingly is associated with what
peanut butter he should be credited with
brilliantly developing farming methods
to enliven the fallow earth his methods
introduced new crops with high protein
content that not only nourished
communities but also replenish the soil
that had been stripped and depleted by
excessive brutal cotton cultivation his
findings allowed new worlds to grow out
of brutal grounds so I think it's a
beautiful name for a school the Carver
school was a product of the NNC and drew
heavily from the ranks of organized
workers I think you can go to the next
one the longshoremen the Marine cooks in
stewards Union which historian Allen
Berube describes as having their own
radical anti-racist anti-sexist and anti
homophobic politics in the ninth
30s and 40s their slogan according to
bear obey was no red-baiting no
race-baiting
and no queen baiting since members knew
that if they could be divided along any
of these lines that could be defeated
the Carver school tied them to the space
of Harlem board members like Ben Davis
harlem's communist councilman was active
in supporting radical black left
institutions others like Dubois and Paul
Robeson were simultaneously part of the
Council on African affairs an
organization that worked in solidarity
with African struggles against
colonialism and apartheid we in
Patterson depicted here in one of
Catlett's later slides of images was
head of the International labor defense
and was one of many members who also
worked with the Civil Rights Congress in
the global campaign to free the
Scottsboro Boys
so Catlett describes moving between
spaces and thinking about harlem police
violence the poverty and dead of its
residents and the gendered
vulnerabilities they experienced in the
context of global anti-fascist and
anti-colonial struggle I think you can
go to the next one
it should be said that World War two had
the unintended consequence of enhancing
women's leadership particularly in the
black left and particularly in Harlem as
Eric Edelman writes a younger group of
black women took over much of the NN
seized operation in New York City so to
tell the story of the Harlem left is to
talk about a world where women like
Maria
Mary Louise Patterson Esther Cooper
Jackson Claudia Jones marbella kook
Augustus Savage s Londa Robeson to just
name a few were all in decisive
leadership positions so building on the
already excellent studies by historians
like Dale Gore Barbra ransbeek Carole
Boyce Davis Sheryl Higashi - Keith
gilyard many many others I think the
Catlett can be more firmly elevated to
the ranks of these leaders as well as
her friend and Carver school director
Gwendolyn Bennett you can go to the next
one
so much Bennett's story can be found
actually you know in some of the
publications of the day this is a
beautiful profile the Chicago Defender
did of her in 1946 but most of it can
actually be found in her FBI file as I
discussed in the large chapter so with
Bennett as with Margaret Burroughs
there's much to say about how these
women's relationships with Catlett were
a critical component of their collective
radical as
but let me say a little bit more about
Catlin Harlem you can go to the next one
so little is written about Catlett's
work while she was in New York City in
oral histories Calot has described only
being a staff illustrator for the NNC
newsletter yet archives show that
Catlett produced much more than
illustration particularly when you look
through her various correspondence with
two boys in one note she writes in her
capacity as executive secretary of an
art initiative in Detroit organized by
the NNC and new masses she asked the
boys to serve as co-chair to quote
combat the campaign of racial antagonism
that is being carried on in Detroit by
followers you can go to the next one of
Gerald LK Smith and other American
Firsters which I in another lower
resolution image but I was trying to
give you a sense of what his followers
look like and also what some of the
residents of their propaganda you know
was that there's a frightening resonance
between some of the American first
language being used today so you know
Katla was trying to organize this effort
to use art and to bring in Du Bois to
like directly confront this American
fascist movement you can go to the next
one Khali was also a very shrewd writer
as could be seen in an article she wrote
for the new masses so in 1946 the
Brooklyn Museum had an exhibit called
the Negro artist comes of age and you
can go to the next one
so Calot wrote this great scathing
review which includes the decisive line
the title itself in itself is an insult
and she says black artists have
contributed to American culture since
the late 18th century had the museum had
the consciousness about style or form
they wouldn't have grouped these art
artists together with nothing uniting
them but the fact that they were black
so she would work in New York and other
very public capacities at one point she
spoke alongside Communist Party leader
William Z Foster at a conference called
art as a weapon and she received a lot
of criticism for this appearance but as
she joked in a later interview so there
I was working in a red
front school and speaking on a program
with William C Foster also I worked with
the committee for the National Negro
Congress that made me a communist three
times but once you know dr. Du Bois said
if you take one step backwards you never
stop running
so I decided not to take that one step
back I think you can go to the next one
in the ferment of Harlem in the 1940s
where as Harold Cruz described quote
nobody gave a damn who you were what
your politics were debates raged between
communist black nationalist
anti-communist and liberals at places
like the YMCA Cruz who is of course
later a fierce anti-communist said at
the time quote anybody that couldn't
argue Marx or angles was considered a
goddamn dummy unquote Cruz took his
first class with the boys at the Carver
school he also took a class on
philosophy by Howard sell some who was a
former professor at Brooklyn College for
ten years
selim had been dismissed by the local
New York rapcore day investigation which
purged suspected leftist from their
teaching jobs many teachers at Carver
were victims of this early Red Scare
hysteria an unfounded assault on public
education as ellen tracker has
powerfully documented usually it was
students who were much more radical on
campus in their teachers students often
only learn that their teachers had been
on the left after hearing that they had
been killed for example in the Spanish
Civil War as one substitute teacher in
Harlem described if you were drawn to
the people who worked hardest to change
things for students you inevitably found
yourself with communists they were the
ones who looked out for their co-workers
who fought against the exploitation
repression faced by students staff or
local neighbors mark Starr mark Starr
whose papers are at the Tama mint and
who was a validly not a communist but he
was head of worker education for the il
gwu he formed the committee at this time
to combat Red Scare attacks on education
and this is what he says in one of those
documents quote talk observer Civ and
immoral activities is nothing but a
smokescreen behind which the enemies of
public education seek to destroy the
economic and intellectual foundations of
our school system I think this is an
important crit
to resurrect so while many talented
teachers lost their jobs in the Red
Scare places like the Carver school
gained the benefit of their labor
initially Carver students cut a wide
swath across Harlem social classes but
after an article by Westbrook Pegler
denounced the school as a red front most
of the middle-class students left as a
result the students of Carver were The
Cook's maids janitors elevator operators
garment industry workers and domestic
workers of New York who took courses for
$3 each and the students quickly
transformed the place as their own young
artist painted the original dreary walls
of the school a volunteering Minister
rolled up his sleeves and glued together
chairs for the students to sit on
McCrory's five-and-dime donated a grand
piano in the first term 157 people came
from trade unions fraternal
organizations youth groups and churches
after three years enrollment rose to 702
students and in a 1946 Chicago Defender
article one student Catherine Henin
describes her experience quote I
wondered why I was receiving such
valuable and capable guidance at so
small a fee what a profound thing to say
how is this possible I thought about my
teacher and why he must have been
interested in the problems of the
working class since he used politics to
illustrate the meaning and use of words
I then began to wonder about other
teachers whether they too were
interested in the problems of workers I
decided that the Carver school must be a
school for the fair thinking people of
this community
why because black and white were serving
side-by-side to aid those of us who
sought a better understanding of life
and problems the curriculum was based
according to what students needed
popular classes included a black history
class taught by Alain Locke and a
Franklin Frazier or when finally of
Juilliard taught music appreciation
Dorothy Homer who was a head librarian
at the hundred 35th Street Public
Library held a class on current book and
social classes the head of price control
caught a taught a course called your
dollar and how to spend it and the
students jokingly suggested that they
would rather have a class called your
dollar and how to get it classrooms
offered students the opportunities to
discuss politics as they unfolded in
Harlem as Catlett recounted
some cops shot a soldier in the back in
a hotel when LaGuardia was mayor and the
people cleaned out of 125th Street and
everything yeah well we analyzed that in
our school why that happened
the most popular class at the Carver
school as a Chicago Defender described
was one called how to make a dress
Catlett taught this popular class and
she recalled common conversations that
she would have about it when people
would ask quote how do you teach Marxism
making a dress and I said Wow well while
we're sewing we talk and when a lady
says I have to leave early to get my
news I say do you know what the news
thinks of you and of black people and we
get into a discussion of why newspapers
are printed and who reads them and what
they support and what they don't support
and that was the way it worked in these
classes Katla would come into the
closest contact with black domestic
workers in Harlem the question a black
domestic workers had occupied the
organizing efforts and theorization of
black radical feminists in Harlem I
think and go to the next one writers
like Alice Childress would go on to
devote much of her freedom ways column
conversations from life to the lives of
black domestic workers Marxist Claudia
Jones would devote a four-page section
to her famous 1949 essay an end to the
neglect of the problems of the Negro
woman to the domestic worker Marvel
Cooke would write a series of articles
about their struggles in 1935 Cooke and
another young organizer Ella Baker
co-authored the famous article Bronx
slave market describing the humiliations
of black domestic workers huddled on
street corners in the early morning
hours awaiting inspection from
middle-class white women for potential
labor for the day and Baker and Cooke
emphasized the role of clothing as
critically enabling or preventing
employment the dress marked the ability
of marketability social class levels of
desperation and its signaled the form of
labor the ware was willing to undertake
quote rain or shine cold or hot you will
find them their women old and young
sometimes bedraggled sometimes neatly
dressed waiting expectantly and go to
the next one
so for black domestic workers dresses
were not just objects of fancy but
necessary for confronting the
complexities of their employment
catalyst material engagement helped
elaborate the multiple forms of
valorisation that was happening through
the dress these articles of clothing
were class signifiers prerequisites for
entrance into different spaces and
places of employment their style color
and upkeep became unstable markers of
employability they needed to be clean to
signal reliability and also stylish
enough to make the wear a conspicuous
object of servitude able to impress the
friends and neighbors of the white women
who hired them these were also objects
of utility necessary to clothe the body
so they needed to be sturdy flexible and
durable enough to work in and his
Catlett recounted it was easier to have
navy blue or brown or black that didn't
show so much dirt these were laughter
these were after all not just costumes
they were uniforms and the dresses also
had to be understood as potential liquid
assets that could be sold in desperate
conditions during one cold winter in
Iowa Catlett had been forced to sell her
own coat in order to afford rent and
food so she understood this relationship
well critically and you can go to the
next one these dresses also had to
subtly convey the wearer's ability I'm
sorry availability or unavailability for
sex work while it was more often wealthy
white women who did the hiring Baker and
Cooke note that husbands sons brothers
under the subterfuge of work offer
worldly wise girls higher bids for their
times these scenes underscored the ways
in which the complex realities of race
gender and class victimized black
domestic workers and force them into
vulnerable entanglements accordingly
clothes had to be complex vectors of
communication aware of the racialized
class and gendered violence that seeds
behind every transaction and I want to
say I had to cut this for time but I
think it's really important to add that
as much as we are talking about you know
these dresses that were made for work
there's also great joy in the dresses
Catlett gave an award to
woman who she thought did a fabulous
aquamarine dress with a particular style
you know and I think you know as like
joy desire love have to be as critical a
part of the analysis but that was a kind
of whole different section of trying to
get us out of here before the clock so
how to make a dress was perhaps one
space where the complex palette politics
of black working-class women's daily
lives could be untangled Catlett even
described learning about how clothing
reflected her students housing
conditions since women quote didn't have
bathrooms or they shared them with
somebody and this also determined where
and how dresses could be washed and
mended so this class was a unique space
within which the complex relations that
went into the commodity of the dress the
commodity of the labor power of these
women and the understanding of capital
not as an abstraction but a practice a
determinant set of social relations
where the inseparability of racism
patriarchy and class could be understood
but if the dresses signaled the
vulnerability of the wearer they could
also become as Peter Stalley brass
writes the materialization of class
resistance you can go to the next one
New York City after all had low
resolution had the highest rates of
unionized black domestic workers as
Esther Cooper Jackson who would be the
future editor of freedom ways magazine
described in her 1940s master's thesis
and this is an article from The Daily
Worker about some of the domestic
workers organizing such organizing was
necessary as the boys would argue in
dark water quote as long as domestic
service was a rule for black people
emancipate emancipation would always
remained a conceptual abstraction so in
these ways the Carver school gave
Catlett the transformative opportunity
to better understand the position of
black working-class women in relation to
global struggles for social change it
also helped her understand how art could
be responsive to their lives and to
political and social movements and so
with this in mind she proposed a series
about the lives of black working-class
women and she submitted an application
to the Rosenwald fellowship to go to
Mexico I think you can go to the next
one
so okay you guys are with me
went to DC went to Texas who went to
Durham North Carolina been all over the
world I have a few things to say about
Mexico and then I'd be really curious
are we okay on time okay a few things to
say about Mexico
so why Mexico why go to Mexico Mexico
had been a part of catless consciousness
since she became studying art in DC
actually her first painting job was to
paint a Diego Rivera style mural and she
was actually fired from the job because
she said she spent too much time
partying and making dresses you can go
to the next one so Diego Rivera perhaps
the most famous of the Mexican muralist
wrote in 1932 quote the importance of
the artist can be measured directly by
the size of the multitudes whose
aspirations and whose life he serves to
condense and translate black artists in
the u.s. particularly since the 30s had
been moved by this intention they shared
with Mexican revolutionary artists a
radical anti-racist ethic a refusal to
promote elite interests or it's racist
aesthetics not only were individual
Mexican muralist great influence on
mural artists in the u.s. the very
inspiration I don't know how many of you
know this the very inspiration for the
federal arts project of the WPA the
Works Progress Administration came from
Mexico that national effort effectively
reframed artists as cultural workers and
subsidized their work and service to the
public and the WPA project changed the
property relation of art putting murals
in quote public possession as head of
the federal Arts Project said making art
the property of all rather than the
hobby of few murals hung in public
buildings and became public entities
that could not be sold to private buyers
it was not uncommon for black artists to
encounter other WPA funded artists who
had been to Mexico and who had worked
with Diego Rivera or with David Alfaro
Siqueiros
or jose clemente orozco were called los
dos tres grandes in turn mexican artists
came to the u.s. especially during the
reactionary period after the revolution
so for many black American artists
Mexico became a Mack
where they were able to develop the
radical training the influence of the
Mexican artist was so strong that the
head of Fine Arts and the WPA vowed to
stop the radical content
he said he devoted to stop what he
called the Mexican invasion on the
border so I'm showing you this image
because the influence of Mexican artists
was very strong in New York City I don't
know how many of you have been to the
new Whitney exhibit which really makes
these kind of cross-fertilization x'
clear so you know this was this is a
very bad image of Rivera painting the
man at the crossroads mural in
Rockefeller Center which was destroyed
shortly after he completed it of course
any of you who have been to new school
have probably seen holy clemente orozco
murals around the new school and there
were a number of exhibitions I think he
can go to the next one leaf Rayford does
a really incredible job of describing
two competing exhibitions that were
organized by the n-double-a-cp and the
Communist Party both protesting lynching
both of them featured Orozco's image
hangmen which was a haunting image of
for black lynch men who are being
consumed by fire and art historians have
subsequently observed that there are a
lot of stylistic similarities between
the way he's depicting lynching an
earlier series he'd done about violence
suffered during the Mexican Revolution
this other piece death or lynched figure
was done by Mexican I'm sorry by
Japanese American artist Isamu Noguchi
who had traveled to Mexico and this work
was also displayed in both exhibits this
haunting sculpture was based on a
photograph of a contorted body you know
somebody who had been lynched and
subsequently set on fire that had been
published by the ILD so the kind of
consciousness of Mexican artists in New
York or artists who had gone to Mexico
and then come back to participate in
struggles against lynching would have
been something that was very much a part
of the fabric of the city
so it was in New York that Catlett met
members of the TRD graphic a couple are
who invited her to join them in Mexico
you can go to the next one
SoCal it received a grows and Wald grant
to travel to Mexico to complete this
series on black women and you can go to
the next one so the Thai Air or tgp took
Commission's from labor organizations
student groups literacy campaigns and
what was really unique about them was
that they produced the symbology being
asked to them together so in joining the
tgp Calot was not just exposed to this
unique collective of artists and this is
a profile of some of the artists from
1956 but she was also exposed to a
unique style of pedagogy as well and you
can go to the next one at the end of the
day the artists would all gather their
work and a fix it to the walls moving
slowly as a group they would stop at
every drawing and discuss Catlett
recounts at the tire we were more or
less
we've worked collectively everyone was
interested in your project
each artist would select a theme go home
and do a drawing then the drawings were
brought in and put up so we could see
how they related to the assignment and
the criticism was always constructive
quote I think the symbolism is very good
someone might say but the drawing is
weak to make it stronger you could
improve the way you drew that hand which
you slurred when you were focusing on
the face let me help you so the success
of the image was the not-yet
the success of the image was the shared
intention of the collective the
collective ask could the image convey
its message to the other artists present
could it the specific elements of the
campaign for which striking students
trade unions or anti-fascist groups had
enlisted their help how might it disrupt
prevailing assumptions about power and
inequality could it in turn communicate
these visions the majority of people in
Mexico and Beyond okay so you have a
snapshot of who this group was now
Catlett had come to mexico to produce a
print series celebrating the lives of
black working-class women which she
later retitled the black woman and when
you place all the images together the
tight
the images can be read as a poem so
after every phrase you're just gonna
have to advance to the next one so I am
the black woman go ahead
I've always worked hard in America in
the fields and other folks homes I've
given the world my songs and Sojourner
Truth I fought for the rights of women
as well as blacks and Harriet Tubman I
helped hundreds to freedom in Phyllis
Wheatley I proved intellectual equality
in the midst of slavery my role has been
important in this in the struggle to
organize the unorganized I have studied
in ever-increasing numbers my reward has
been bars between me and the rest of the
land
I have special reservations special
houses and a special fear for my loved
ones my future my right is a future of
equality with other Americans so when
Khalid arrived at the tgp artists were
in the middle of producing a series on
the history of the Mexican Revolution
you go to the next one the estamos de la
revolucion Makana
is a series of 85 lino cuts and Catlett
was clearly moved by what she saw go
ahead to the next one and let me just
tell you really briefly like this whole
thing I'm presenting to you today is
just really my attempt to solve a
mystery which when I went to Stanford to
look at this collection and went through
it and then found this collection in the
same box I had to make sense of what I
was looking at and when you look at the
images side by side I think a number of
stylistic political and historical
resonance become clear so you can go to
the next one so for example in the Tai
airs you have prominent images of heroes
of the revolution like Pancho Villa and
in Catlett you have you know
similarly positioned black women like
Harriet Tubman you go to the next one or
another Zapata and Sojourner Truth and
you go to the next one
significantly both series also celebrate
the experiences of ordinary men and
women their lives as workers musicians
grievers fighters and organizers so you
know one of my effort is just to make
sense of why these two series are so
similar if you can go to the last one we
don't have time but it was actually when
I saw and a special fear for my loved
ones and realized I'm not sure how well
you can see the gesture of the hands but
you know feeling a kind of deja vu like
that there was just a lot of stylistic
similarity between how these two bodies
were positioned what the kind of
location in the foreground and
background what these different
stylistic elements were trying to do
that I had to go back and start thinking
about these two decisively together if
we had more time I'd love to talk about
the kind of residence between these two
images but given some of our technical
difficulties and the late hours of the
day I'm going to just try to wrap up
here so you can go to the next one by
way of conclusion let me just say this
in 1942 there's this great record where
Catlett debated the concept of
internationalism with her teacher
osip's ad Caen so Catlett in addition to
going to the Carver school also took
private lessons with this russian-born
sculptor in his Coldwater Greenwich
Village studio sadly that Ken who was
Jewish had come to New York City after
fleeing the Nazis in Paris like
Picasso's famous depictions of fascism
in Guernica or Shostakovich his musical
composition against fascism that Ken's
work was also motivated by the fight
against fascism his modernist sculptures
took on themes of suffering the
destruction of cities and war and
universal pain his artwork he explained
was necessarily internationalist in this
moment of global crisis amidst the rise
of fascism he has Catlett why she
insisted on sculpting images of black
women and children a theme he asserted
that was limited
decidedly nationalist and Calvin would
have none of it in a 2002 interview she
recounted how she pushed that kid on his
definition of internationalism why
couldn't people identify with the black
mother and child the way they might with
his so-called internationalist imagery
she asked what made him assume that her
artwork was limited instead of
universally identifiable and why did he
presume that his sculpture of a male
poet adorned with a French poem on it
wasn't itself nationalist so to recover
the political life of Elizabeth Catlett
broadens our conception of
internationalism and opens this still
urgent question around the world people
right now are confronting violent racist
sexist settler colonial nationalist
movements here in the US we are seeing a
frightening rise of white supremacist
nationalism so at this moment I think
it's imperative that we recover the
submerged history of Catlett's
internationalism a tradition essential
for our survival thank you
[Applause]
sure sure sure I'm so excited about your
question right now
yes oh god what an invitation I'll keep
you guys here for two more hours
what a beautiful question I don't know
how many of you are in the class that
read the piece I wrote that begins with
the Haitian Revolution but you know I
wrote this piece that starts off with
the first instance of the use of aerial
surveillance in the Americas and it was
during the Haitian Revolution and
there's this amazing story of this hot
air balloon that took off from this
plantation that later was a plantation
where you know the first uprisings of
the Haitian Revolution began so you know
I wrote that and as soon as I wrote it I
was like I think all my work is about
surveillance in a way that maybe I
haven't even fully digested so once you
said the word I was like are you a plant
did you materialize from my subconscious
because it's a question I'm trying to
figure out and what I conclude or you
know how I introduced that piece is you
know I tried to contrast that like the
the vision the way of seeing the
illusion of omniscience right of the
French colonial powers right this idea
that they were all-knowing all-seeing
that you know by the technology of the
hot air balloon they could not only
conquer land they can conquer air and so
what an extraordinary rebuttal to have
like you know the arrogance of that
rebuffed with the Haitian Revolution
breaking out right where that was
launched and so what I conclude by
saying is that you know we can't think
of surveillance as a position of
dominance but the anxiety of regime
aware of its own illegitimate see and I
think retooling surveillance is really
helpful for understanding a consistent
dialectic in terms of you know the
struggle thank you
the what what we're thinking about and
obviously you're pointing to stylistic
[Laughter]
yes well I'm not an art historian you
know I just play one on TV YouTube so
you know I mean it's one of the things
that I am really you know it I mean it's
like the story of looking at those two
series at Stanford and then just kind of
having an intuition that there was
something similar there right and then
having to read from a lot of very smart
art historians who could sort of explain
this is what those styles meant you know
I think the mode of production of art at
this time itself
I think is something I'm really
fascinated by right you know Calot is a
sculptor she adores sculpture you know
this is what she trained in at the
University of Iowa but because of her
experiences at the Southside Community
Arts Center in Chicago because of her
experience with the wash with the
Washington Carver school because of her
experiences in Mexico she you know has
this transition where she says now look
you know sculpture is beautiful and
powerful but you can't pass a sculpture
around now Alyssa graph or a line of cut
you know those are prints those are
prints that allow you to replicate an
image very quickly very cheaply so that
a lot of people can have them so you
know I mean there's a kind of
interesting I don't know you know I mean
if I was smarter I'd probably have the
introduction in dialogue with Benjamin's
you know work of art in the age of
mechanical reproduction too just because
I think the question of reproduction and
making art that could be easily
reproduced you know like so thinking
about gestures that could tell a lot
rather than highly detailed things that
were harder to carve into a line of cut
you know I think there's a lot of
translating work that she's having to do
when she starts thinking that the
reproduction of these images are so
critical to the politics itself but like
I said I'm kind of a poser and these
things
I'm learning thanks for the question yes
mmm
so I'm gonna have to get both your names
at the end so I can properly credit you
for helping consolidate a lot of the
ideas in my book cuz you know I don't
think either one were necessarily
apparent to me I mean in that essay that
you read I'm drawing on Clyde Woods's
work and he explains blues epistemology
in his you know classic book development
arrested and it was a question that he
asked us to think really hard about you
know Dan showed the images of some of
the readers that I was involved with the
first one was about militarized policing
and Skid Row Los Angeles and Clyde from
his deathbed said you have to talk about
housing and you have to think about the
blues epistemology there so you know
whether acknowledge or unacknowledged
it's definitely the subconscious that I
think I'm thinking about in all my work
and I wouldn't have you know until you
said it really thought about like how
blues epistemology does help crystallize
a lot of the insights I'm trying to make
about Catlett and them in the
revolutionary milieu she was a part of
so you know I mean with full respect I
think I have to like step back and think
about your comment and how I'm putting
those two things together because I
think it's probably been more
subconscious and it's been overt but
that's you know for clarification
purposes it probably should be overt so
benjamine clyde woods you guys are
writing the intro I really appreciate it
yes which one did you read yes
yes well I don't have mm-hmm okay we can
try I have some extra slides at the end
you can just go forward which I hope is
here so some of these are actually
images that the Thai air did in the
years after Catlett came which are I
like you know I mean I had to find these
in a lot of archives and go how come
nobody has just told the story you can
keep going of how it was you know what
was the consciousness of this Mexicans
you know Mexico City internationalist
art collective thinking about all these
different figures so you can go to the
next one like for example this is
actually can you go to the next one this
so this is not a piece by Catlett but I
am 78 percent sure that that's her I
mean she had these characteristic
glasses and you go to the next one so
you can go to the next one maybe I don't
have it here III thought I had some
slides of Catlett's actually
contribution to the images of the
Mexican Revolution because it's actually
I mean here's maybe the conclusion of
this chapter so you know each of these
85 prints tell a different you know
phase in the story of the Mexican
Revolution she does one of the later
ones under Cardenas right and so it's
all of these Mexican people supporting
the effort to nationalize oil in the
country right and so there's a number of
farmers who are bringing chickens there
some people bringing a few coins but
what she has in the foreground of this
image are women with sewing machines
right all putting them on the table as
their contribution so I was excited to
show you that just to show you that
there are different ways that she was
you know I mean she's really thinking in
a broad way what is internationalism
mean what does it mean with the
connections I have in the United States
what does it mean to throw in with these
revolutionaries who are based in Mexico
City but are trying to also speak to the
world and I think that she's got a
particular attendance to what the local
history and struggles look like thank
you yes
so that's a partial answer to your
question it's it's a big question and
you know she lives in Mexico
for 65 years so this is at the heart of
her art production and her teaching and
her politics
constitution-making just I've never seen
a presentation so captured
[Applause]
[Music]